the batman's played a joke on all of us
i'm just here to unmask the truth about
this
city the batman offers significant
changes to characters general audiences
thought they knew well all you have to
do is take a look at the caped crusader
himself played this time around by
robert pattinson while he's the world's
greatest detective in the comics that
side of him had never really been
explored in a live-action film before
that all changes in the batman as he's
on the hunt for a mysterious serial
killer going by the name of riddler he
has to solve the clues and to further
add to the detective aesthetic batman
speaks in voiceover like an old-school
noir film of course some things are
destined to remain the same forever such
as batman's eternal struggle with the
joker in virtually every iteration of
the character the caped crusader has a
tussle with the clown prince of crime
and lo and behold the joker does make a
brief appearance in the batman after the
riddler's safely in custody he speaks
with his next-door cellmate and while he
never mentions his name it's fairly
obvious this character played by barry
keoghan supposed to be the newest
version of the joker getting to be that
is like
yeah
the words can't destroy them for years
all of dc's cinematic efforts came to
exist under the banner of the dc
extended universe similar to the marvel
cinematic universe this meant that all
of the characters existed under one roof
so batman could appear in a superman
movie and vice versa however unlike the
mcu this venture has become stilted in
recent years as the massive team-up film
justice league bailed to ignite a
franchise
since that time some movies have kept
the series going like birds of prey
however other dc projects have come to
exist in their own continuity such as
2019's joker prior to its release there
was confirmation that the batman would
exist in its own separate continuity
however there were questions if it would
connect to any other dc efforts
particularly joker where joaquin phoenix
portrayed the famed villain with the
above mentioned scene in the batman we
know now once and for all that the
batman won't connect to anything that's
come before by all appearances a new
joker is in town however that doesn't
mean that batman will exist in a vacuum
it's already been confirmed that two
spin-offs are in the works on hbo max
the first will center on the gotham
police department while the other
focuses on colin farrell's penguin
there's even the possibility that if the
batman 2 filmmakers don't want to use
joker as the villain in that movie he
could pop up on one of these shows to
wreak havoc it would seem the batman is
forging a new path ahead for dc projects
and while he may be the dark knight the
future couldn't be brighter
don't worry honey i got nine of them
with dc tampering with the multiverse in
the upcoming flash movie it's clear that
while some films will exist within the
dc eu others will exist separately in
their own universes of course as marvel
has already shown us with spider-man no
way home the multiverse is a delicate
concept and can easily break to the
point where other realities merge with
others as of right now three live action
jokers have appeared in dc theatrical
films as of late in addition to barry
kyogen's cameo in the batman there's
also joaquin phoenix's oscar-winning
portrayal of the clown prince of crime
and joker jared leto also recently
revived his version of the character for
zack snyder's justice league after
playing him for 2016 suicide squad that
makes for three live-action jokers out
there not even getting into all of the
cartoons and video games that have
featured him in recent memory it's an
intriguing development especially seeing
how dc comics has introduced the concept
of three jokers in the mainline dc
continuity in the limited series batman
3 jokers batman realizes that different
versions of joker are out there not only
does it make for a thrilling adventure
but it also serves as a meta commentary
on the purpose and function of the
villain in these stories could a live
action version of the story materialize
with the three jokers we have now
uniting for one wild and crazy escapade
it's a long shot but wilder things have
happened in the world of comic book
movies
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]